هل سنشهد ركودًا
وسأسمح لك بتعريفه بهذه الطريقة
الولايات المتحدة والاقتصاد العالمي ، لذا
دعني أقول فقط أننا سنواجه ركودًا
في العديد من البلدان التي تشمل ألمانيا
وإيطاليا وسنغافورة واليابان وتلك القائمة
ستذهب إلى  للحصول على وقت أطول ، نحن الولايات
المتحدة ، لا يزال الوضع 50/50 ، ولكن
إذا استمرت اضطرابات السوق
وإذا تضخم الخوف من فيروس كورونا ،
فلسوء الحظ سنكون هذه هي المرة الأولى
منذ عقود التي تحدث فيها
أزمة مالية عالمية منسقة لذلك
لأن هناك  سيظل نموًا
سيعوض أولئك الذين هم في حالة ركود
لا وعليك أن تفهم
شيئين ، أحدهما يتعلق بالاقتصاد
والآخر يتعلق بالأسواق والاقتصاد الذي نواجه فيه
تدميرًا للطلب والعرض
في نفس الوقت لماذا لأن
فيروس كورونا يخلق  توقفك فجأة
ولم أعد أرغب في السفر ،
فنحن لم نعد شخصًا واحدًا سنقوم برحلة
الأشياء التي تمنعك ، لذا
ندمر الطلب والعرض في نفس الوقت اللذين
يحدثان عادةً في حالة جزئية  في الدول الفاشلة
وليس في الاقتصادات الحديثة ، تعتبر الظروف الأولية الثانية
مهمة من أين تبدأ
، وتذكر أن
الصورة البسيطة التي شاركتها معك على مدار
الأشهر القليلة الماضية ، هنا الأساسيات
هنا والفرق هو الثقة في
البنك المركزي